Hi guys, good evening. Am I audible? Okay, thank you. So sorry for the delay. I don't
take all of this time. Okay.
and then we will start the class
meanwhile if you have any questions
you can ask
good evening, good evening everyone
if you have any questions you can ask
yeah
there is a small announcement
if you remember we were studying benchmarks
and there we were studying different model capabilities
I have given you knowledge capabilities
and you can also use it as a benchmark
so if you want to learn more about
the different models
you can also use it as a benchmark
and you can also use it as a benchmark
I have given you knowledge capabilities
in very detailed
and I have promised you that
we will provide you lectures on other capabilities
and I have promised you that we will provide you lectures on other capabilities
so now in your dashboard
you will get to see lectures
on three other capabilities
one is
reasoning
one is maths
and the last one is coding
so we have recorded three so far
there are big lectures, properly covered
there are two hours of lectures
so whenever you get time
you can see it once
you will have knowledge
and the three or four capabilities left
such as
instruction following
long context
or safety
we are recording lectures on these
and it will take one more week
and you will get that too
in the dashboard
it is on you
you can cover it on your own pace
ok?
I have missed some of the classes in between
can I pick up the class from today
or should I come here after
completing back notes?
honestly today's class doesn't depend
on the previous classes
so you can attend this one
and the next one also
meanwhile whenever you get time
you can cover some of the things
you can attend today's class
there will be no problem
so what I will do is
I will first of all share my screen
and let's start our
session
ok?
let's start the session
so
what we are going to do in the session
before I tell you about it
I would like to give a recap
of this playlist
because we have covered
two big milestones in this playlist
so you should know
where we are lying
in the whole curriculum
so in the LLMEval
playlist
we have covered three or four lectures
which we spent
in the introduction
or you can say fundamentals
where we
understood
why LLMEval is needed
what are LLMEval
we covered all these things
we discussed
reference based evals, reference free evals
we discussed online evals
offline evals
we discussed all these concepts
and the most important concept we discussed
was that there are two types of LLMEval
one is model evals
and the other is
application evals
and we discussed that
we will focus more on application evals
but
we first
covered model evals
which we are doing in the last two or three sessions
so while studying model evals
we discussed that
model evals also have two types of evals
one is standardized evals
which we call
benchmarks
which we
studied knowledge capability
where we discussed multiple benchmarks
that
comes under this topic
and then we also discussed
that according to your application
when you have to choose a model
you can run custom
model evals
which you make your own dataset
and run
so we covered this in the previous lecture
so in short
we have covered
so much in this playlist
and now the most important
part of this playlist is
which is this
application evals
and we will start from today
from today we will learn that
if you have an LLMEval based application
then how can you evaluate it
based on all the knowledge
that we have gathered till now
and
here also you have to understand
that there can be
many types of LLME based applications
right
so you can have simple chatbots
or you can have
rack based chatbots
agents
all of these are examples of LLME
based applications
so if I give you an example of LLME
then it can be multi model apps
basically such applications
where
apart from text
in some modality
for example
image generator
that is also an LLME based application
but there you are generating image
then you can have
fixed
schema
output
type of application
where your application
uses LLME and gives
fixed schema output
which can be an example of Zomato
which case study we discussed
2-3 lectures before
where you are reading the email
its content and you are classifying
it as support email
or
refund email or technical email
so here output
will follow a fixed schema
so this is also a type of LLME based application
so honestly
it is not possible for me
to teach you all
kind of applications and their
application evals
I can't teach you how to run
application eval on chatbots
on rack
on agents
so I had to
select
and I had in mind that I will teach you
2 things
I have selected 2 things
which we are going to study
1st is rack
because it is very important
most of the chatbots
that you will build
in your professional journey
will have rack functionality
so rack becomes very important
in that sense and 2nd
I will teach you agents application
eval
because agents is also very important
so the rest of the things
which is a simple chatbot
which doesn't have any function of rack
or agent
I am not teaching you how to evaluate that
I would expect that
if you read more difficult things
then you will automatically
do easy things
this one is also kind of easy
this is also kind of easy
multimodal
app is a little different
I would not say it is difficult
it is slightly different from the other things
but anyway you can do it
the only thing is that
they exist less in production setup
means there are very few companies
very few projects which are of multimodal nature
mostly you will see rack
and agent design patterns
that is why we are going to cover
rack and agents
application eval going forward
so now
today's session and next 2-3 sessions
which are going to be
on rack eval
basically we will make a rack chatbot
and we will properly
evaluate it
and after watching these 3-4 sessions
you will be able to answer
this very important interview question
very easily
the question is
how do you
evaluate
your
rack chatbot
very famous question
for JNAI interviews
almost 8 out of 10
interviews are asked
and most of the times students
are not able to give convincing answers
many people don't know
because they have never studied evals
those who have studied evals
they are not able to give structured answers
I guarantee you that if you watch
today's session and next 3-4 sessions properly
then you
will be able to give a very proper answer
and you will impress the other person
that is my guarantee
so I hope I was able to explain to you
where we are existing in this playlist
and what is our next direction
our next direction
is based on whatever we have
learned so far
we are going to use that to read rack evals
with the help of a case study
so is this entire
discussion clear? I took around 5-10 minutes
but this clarity is very important
in the starting so that is why
I told you in detail
let me know if you have any doubts
questions, confusion, anything
you can tell me
if not
then we will move ahead
I will just wait for 30 seconds
if any question comes I will answer
ok
so I guess most likely things are clear
so now we
start our
rack eval
obviously first of all
we need a
rack project
which we will evaluate
so I will tell you
what this project is
I did not choose
very fancy
problem statement intentionally
I had very good problem statements
in which
you can do very different things
in the process of making the application
but I felt that
our focus here
instead of making a very fancy
rack application
how can we evaluate
a simple rack application
and that is why
I have taken a very simple problem statement
it will be a rack chart bot
but it will be simple
but you will enjoy doing its evaluation
so what we are building is
we are basically building
a campus x
doubt
solver
so basic problem statement
premise is that
you are doing this course
of LLMEval
where we take around 2 lectures every week
and at the end of every lecture
we provide you
recording and
transcript
of the lecture
so till now every lecture
has a transcript
so what we will do is
use these transcripts as
documents
and we will feed these documents in LLME
and then with this LLME
you can ask
any doubt which is in this
playlist
so basically we are making a rack chart bot
for this particular course
with the help of all the transcripts
that we have
I won't explain how the rack works
I am pretty sure you have read it so many times
that you know how the rack works
retriever, generator
and a vector database
an embedding model
you understand all of that
so it is not going into working but roughly explaining
the problem statement that we are going to
build a simple campus x doubt
solver for this particular course
I am not talking about other courses
just LLMEval course
because we have
transcripts of every lecture of this course
so what we will do
we will first
build this
chart bot, this rack project
and then we will evaluate it
in fact
in the process of building it
we will also evaluate it
so I hope you understood the problem statement
there is nothing special to explain here
so let's move ahead
and discuss the most important thing
that when
this chart bot is built
then how will we evaluate it
we understand this
so we are going to
make a proper
eval suite
I think I have taught you this in
a lecture, I don't know if you remember
that whenever you make
an LLM based application
then it doesn't have just one
single evaluation
it has multiple evaluations
so we are going to do that
that we will evaluate our
made rack chart bot from every angle
at different levels
and we will deploy it
only after all those evaluations
and even after
all those evaluations we will evaluate it
with the help of online evals
so the whole process
of this rack chart bot
evaluation, I want to share
that framework with you
so the first and
most important thing
that we will evaluate our rack chart bot
at three levels
the first level will be
component level
second level
pipeline
pipeline level
and third level
application or system level
I have already
taught you this
that you can evaluate any LLM based application
at three levels
these are the three levels
so first of all let's talk about
component level
what you do at component level
is that the time you are building a rack chart bot
at that time
you also evaluate the components
so
we will have to discuss a little
about the architecture of the rack chart bot
you must know that you have a
retriever
and you have a generator
and you have
a vector database
in which
all your documents
are stored in the form of vectors
as soon as you get a query
you send that query
to the vector database
so what the vector database does
is that it sends
the closest four to five relevant
documents
basically this whole work is
of retriever
so the retriever gives you
question plus relevant context
you send this question and relevant context
to the generator
and the generator
generates an answer about both these things
this is the working of a basic
rack chart bot
so if you want to develop step by step
obviously what you will do first
you will build this retriever
once this retriever is built
then you will build this generator
and you will connect both of them
so this pipeline
you call it a rack
so our strategy will be
that on step one
first of all
we will build the retriever
basically we will write the retriever code
so here you do all the work
you load the documents
chunk them
put them in the embedding model
and convert them into vectors
and after that with the help of a retriever
you will bring a new query and fetch relevant documents
so we call this whole work
the retriever
so as soon as we build this retriever
in step two
we will immediately
evaluate this retriever
independently, just the retriever
we are not focusing on the entire application
right now our entire focus is
that the retriever we have built
is it working properly or not
and the retriever
is working properly
it means that given a question
is my retriever
able to fetch the right documents
from the vector database
or not
so here we will use two metrics for evaluation
one will be recall
which tells
how many of the right documents
I was able to bring
and the second is precision
which means
how many of the documents
I brought were of use
so we will evaluate
our retriever on both of them
and once this evaluation is done
and we are satisfied
that our retriever is working properly
then we will move to step three
and in step three
we will start
building our generator
so now we will write the generator code
generator is basically
an LLM in which you give
a question and relevant context
and that generator
gives you an answer in return
so we will build this in isolation
and after building this
we will evaluate this
in step four
and in evaluating this
you will learn two or three metrics
one will be faithfulness
which basically tells
whether the answer is generated
in the given context
or the model hallucinated
by itself
so we will check this
second we will check
that your answer
generated
is relevant with the question
and third
we will judge citation accuracy
so you must have seen
that chart GPTB sometimes gives
answers by looking at a document
so you must have seen that
I have picked this up from this document
or from this link
so we call this citation
so what is our doubt solver
doing?
solving a doubt for a given question
so along with that he will tell us
that this question
which session Nitesh sir
discussed, so we will provide the link
of that transcript
so we will judge citation accuracy
in the generator
important thing
we will evaluate the generator
in isolation
which basically means
that at this point your generator
is not connected
to the retriever
which basically means that
we will manually
provide some question
and context
kind of like a golden dataset
we are providing independently
retrievers are not getting
any input, we have not made this pipeline
we are doing component level
evaluation
once this is evaluated
in isolation, generator
and we are satisfied that this generator
is working well on its own
then our level
will achieve
that we have done things at component level
our retriever is working well in isolation
our generator is working well in isolation
we are done with the stage one
after that
we come to the next stage
which is step five
where now what we will do
we will build our rag pipeline
rag pipeline means
that we will connect
our retriever and generator
very simple code
connected, after this
comes step six
where we will check that
when these two are connected
and a pipeline is formed
is this pipeline working properly
or not
and here the evaluation
is a very famous term
we call it rag
triad
so basically what you do here
as soon as you make rag pipeline
you check three
metrics
and we call these three metrics rag triad
why I tell you
so three things are existing here
first of all the user's question
the context we have got
from vector database
which has brought the retriever
and the answer generated
by generator
these three things exist
so
in these three
pairs
three metrics exist
like for question and context
a metric exists
which we call context
relevance
which tells
that for a given question
the context
which has been fetched from retriever
is it relevant or not
with the question
second is
answer and context
we call this faithfulness
this basically
tells us that the answer
generated is it
generated from context or
something hallucinated the model
and third you will check
that is there a relation
between answer and question
and the metric for this we call
answer relevance
here basically
it is told that given a question
the answer generated is
relevant for the question or not
so we
in isolation
test these three metrics
of our rag pipeline
if these three metrics
are working properly
it means that your rag pipeline
is working properly
and if these three metrics are done
then our particular level
will be done
so so far the flow
is clear to everyone, what we are doing
we are not doing that we have made
our rag chart board first
and then we are evaluating it
no, this is not how it works
your building the chart board
and evaluating it
it works together, it is just like software
software we don't do that
that you make the whole application and then
test it, no, you
test it at the feature level and function level
here exactly the same is happening
that you tested your components
when you joined the components
you tested the pipeline
now your application is there
so you will test it at the application level
so I really hope you are understanding
the flow till now, okay
so now
now that we have tested
the pipeline, next is
that now on step 7
do application level testing
here basically you are testing
that your application, the downed
solver is working properly or not
so here
there are many more metrics
so one very important metric is
correctness
the answer that has come out
is it correct or not
you have to find out this
then there is another metric
which we call completeness
completeness tells that
given a question, is the answer
completely
answering that question or not
suppose there are two parts in your question
but the answer that you got
is answering only one part and ignoring the other part
so there is no completeness
even though the answer of one part is correct
but there is no completeness
so we will check that too
third, we will check style
we will try
that our
campusx downed solver
its explanation style is same
which is of campusx teachers
we will evaluate this also
and you can do this
so this also comes in application level
evaluation
so these are some quality related metrics
apart from this, if you talk about application level
then you will also
test safety here
you will check that your response
is not toxic
or you will check that your
response is not giving any
personally identifiable information
you will check that
your campusx downed solver
can't be jailbreak
so we will do these safety
evaluations on step no.8
on step no.8
we will
run safety evaluations
on this application
and lastly
comes operations evaluations
where you check 3 things
primarily, your latency
of the application, cost
how much you are getting per query
and how many tokens you are spending
so this comes in step no.9
we call this
ops evaluations
we will test this
so
this whole thing
that I have told you
component, pipeline and application
these three levels
that we are evaluating
our whole application
we call this in combined form
eval suite
this is like our entire
testing suite
whenever we want to test our application
then we don't run just one test
we run all these tests
together
then we get to know
from every aspect
is our application working right
or not
so we are going to do so many tests
so many evaluations
this will be our evaluation strategy
so at this point I will take a break
and I will take questions
if you have any doubts
you can ask, this is what we are going to do
in the next 3-4 sessions
but primarily we are going to do these things
let me know if you have any questions
guys
any question till this point
something like
what you think I have missed
what should have been
for a rad chart bot
or any other suggestion
or any doubt
are we going to generate golden data sets
yes Amar
there are many evals
for which you will have to generate golden data sets
some evals are also
where you don't need golden data sets
so
you will know that
in most of the cases
you will need golden data sets
and you will have to generate golden data sets
so yeah
the answer is yes
any other question
at this point
ok
ok, this question
was a good reminder
till now
whatever classes we have done
in that we were
making evals, we were writing the code
especially if you have seen the last lecture
where we were
running custom model evals
you must have seen that we were writing our own code
but we are not
going to do that in this case
if we write all this code ourselves
then it will be a very big project
instead what we will do is
we will use a library
which is called deep eval
in deep eval
if you go then you will see
that from the discussions
there are many metrics
already exist
like here
if you go to rag
then you will see answer relevancy, faithfulness
contextual precision recall
contextual relevancy
all these things already exist
then if you go to safety
then toxicity
PII leakage
all these things already exist
so instead of writing
custom code to evaluate
our rag application
we will instead use this great library
called deep eval
which is the state of the art library
most of the big companies
use this library
to do LLM based evaluations
and the best part about this library is
that it is based on
the main library of python
for software testing
so if you have ever done software testing
using PITest
then this library will make you feel at home
so we are going to use this library
we are not going to use ragas
because you can use both
you can do all this in ragas
and deep eval
I am selecting deep eval
particularly because of two reasons
first is ragas we have already studied
in the advanced rag course
second
deep eval is a broader library
its scope
is even more
like agents where you can see here
agents, multi turn chat bots
non LLM applications
image based applications
for all kinds of things you can use deep eval
so that is why its adoption is also more
and there is a good chance that
after a year or two
this NLM evaluations
will become
a benchmark library
it will become the standard
so its a good strategy that we are focusing more on deep eval
I really hope you don't have any problem with this
yeah ragas is good
obviously there is no problem with this
as I have already told you two reasons
we have already covered this
and second deep eval is a better library
in comparison to ragas
so yeah
any other question is point pin
move forward
okay
now
a very important discussion
once you
make such a eval suite
which we have also made
after that
comes a very important task
which we call regression
testing
after that we do
regression testing
what is regression testing?
regression testing is basically
the act of
running
your
eval
suite
on your
application
till now what we are doing
we are building our eval suite
we are writing different
evaluation codes
for different different components
and pipelines and applications
once everything is done
then when you run it
on the whole application
we call this regression testing
the simple foundation of regression testing
is that if your version
one of the software is running
now you have made version two
of the same software
so how do you know version two
is objectively not
worse than version one
is my application worse
how do I test if it is not
better than version one
this is the answer you get in regression testing
so there is nothing special in regression testing
basically the eval suite you have made
you run it
once
and by running you get results
you get a whole report
that this is in this metric
this is in this metric
this is more than that
so by running this whole regression testing
you get a very clear picture
so the new version of the software
we have made
is it objectively better than the previous version
or not
and on the basis of that
we decide whether we will deploy
the new version or not
so I will explain it in simple words
so what will happen
step by step
we will make a project folder
in that project folder
there will be a folder called src
in which we will write our
source code
here will be our retriever file
generator file, rag pipeline file
we can use fast api
to make api
we can use streamlit
to make ui
so all this will be in src
apart from that in our project folder
there will be another folder called eval
in which all our evaluation files will be
so here you will have
a retriever
.py file
or eval
retriever.py file
which will basically do this
then you will have
similarly another file
which will be called
eval
generator.py
in which we
will write the code to evaluate it
similarly you can understand
a rag pipeline
will have a different file
an application
will have a different file to test
a different file for safety
a different file for operations
so basically all these files
in the eval folder
where we have written all our tests
we call this
our eval suite
and then what will happen
outside all the folders
we will have
a file which we will call
run evals.py
and what code will be written in this
as soon as we
trigger this file
then what will this file do
one by one
all these tests
will be
run on our application
and
will generate a report
and will give it
and when you
analyze that report
then you will understand
that your new version
of the software
is objectively better
than the previous version
your retriever file
is telling that your new retriever
is better than the previous one
the new generator
is telling that the new generator
is better than the previous one
and so on
I guess you understand
this is how you do regression
testing. Is the concept of
regression testing clear?
what did we do step by step?
we made an application
in the process of making the application
we built our eval suite
in which we created multiple evaluation files
and then to run all
these evaluation files
we have a single code
which is run eval.py
so whenever our application is complete
or changes are done
then we run this run eval.py file
and it gives us
a report
that where does the new version
stand in comparison to the previous one
this helps us understand
whether we should deploy the new version
or not. Is everything clear?
is it clear?
simple right?
nothing is too difficult here
now
now I want to explain one more thing
here
the discussion we will do now
will be more in the
LLM ops domain
rather than
just evaluation but I want to tell you
because it is related
so regression testing
is very
kind of advanced
method
what I told you is a very basic method
that you just run this file
what this file did
compared all your metrics
compared to the previous version
and told whether the new version is better
or not but in this
many more things can be done
what I will tell you
the first thing is
that in this
you can do experiment
tracking
so if you have read ML ops
then you might have heard about ML flow
which we use
to run multiple
experiments on our application
so here also you can do
exactly the same thing
so basically what you will do is
that you built your application for the first time
now
you will have some settings
right?
for chunking
how many characters you are using
how much overlap
how much temperature
you are using
some settings related to your embedding model
so
you have kept all these settings
and you have run
this eval suite
for the first time
so what this eval suite
will do is
for all the metrics
it will give you some numbers
for example
your retriever
recall
came to 0.82
and precision
came to 0.68
so in this way
every metric will have some numbers
so what you will do is
the run you have done to your software
and all the configuration numbers
and the metrics numbers
you will go and log them
where? on ML flow like software
so basically experiment 1
these were the configuration values
around that
we got these metric values
and what you will call this
you will call this your baseline
that when we run the software for the first time
we got these readings
after that you thought
let's improve a little
so to improve you went
you increased the size of chunking
reduced the size of overlapping
and again
you run it
with the help of this file
now for new settings
new readings came
so now you can go and log it
so you can compare it
visually
you get a dashboard
and on that dashboard
you can compare
every metric
that how I ran it last 10 times
so how this metric is going up and down
so this regression testing
is called experiment tracking
and this part
is called dashboarding
so this
basic level regression testing can also be done
and if you want to make it more advanced
then add an experiment tracker
and a dashboard tool
so it gets a little better
infact you can make it better
by adding
CI to the mix
CI stands for
continuous integration
so what you will do is
that you will take a CI tool
for example you
took a github action
and what you did
you put
some conditions
there that as soon as you
change anything in your code
and push git
suppose you changed the size
of chunking value
and pushed it
so as soon as you changed the code
you wrote this code in your CI
that as soon as anything changes in the code
then run eval
again
run eval suite again
and as soon as it runs
basically a new set of
readings will come
you will quickly compare
those readings with the current baseline
if
your current reading
is less than the baseline
you will define a threshold
that should not be less than 0.3
suppose it is less
so what you will do instantly
you will pause your new deployment
you will say
that the new change that has been made
I cannot deploy it
because my current baseline
is worse than that
so the software
is regressed, it is bad
on the other hand if you
changed the baseline a lot
and your baseline improved
then you will allow
that now you get deployed
so basically
with the help of CI
you can create a gating mechanism
which will
allow you to
easily, without any tension
change the software
bring improvements in it
and push it
and deploy it
and it will deploy only
when your changes
bring some positive
impact on your current
baseline otherwise it will
be rejected so I really hope you
understand how this whole thing
is handled by an engineering team
so you guys
built an evaluation suite
we are using that
evaluation suite in regression
testing as a gating
mechanism I really hope you
understand this all I will show you
by the way CI
I am not really sure if I can show you
continuous integration or not but
most likely Himanshu will show it to you
because it will be taught to you in LLM Ops
I could have skipped this topic
but I thought since it is
related so I will teach you once
so is this point clear
which I also said even if
let's say if you don't know all this
you have not studied in ML Ops
in that case no problem you can ignore
it
then also you will understand things
I have taught a little extra
so on the basis of discussion
so far
our whole eval strategy is
that we are building an eval suite
on three levels and with the help of
that eval suite we are doing regression
testing now in regression testing
we have discussed three levels first
level simple regression testing
where we are running the software
once and bringing baseline numbers
then every time
running and bringing the next number
and comparing manually
with that we are understanding that
our software is improving or not
level number two you can automate it
by adding a experiment tracking
tool such as MLflow
so now what are you doing
every time you are triggering your eval pipeline
every time according to your configuration settings
the matrix value is getting logged
and you can see it visually with the help
of a dashboard so it got a little better
and what is a better strategy than this
that you use this whole thing
for automation
bring the CI tool in the picture
and tell it that whenever
I run my eval pipeline
automatically test
that my new version of the software
is its matrix better
than my baseline or not
if it is better than the baseline
then we will also do deployment
and we will change our baseline to the new
matrix and you do this continuously
so this is how this entire thing is
done
so is it clear
whatever we discussed so far
Krishna is asking for these
tracking we will use MLflow
or LAMFuse
honestly Krishna
I don't have a plan right now
to teach you experiment tracking
or to teach you CI so the regression
testing I will teach you will be
first level where we will run
those reports
and we will show it in demand prompt
and from there we will discuss whether it is better
or bad
so I am making it level 1
Himanshu will make you level 2 and level 3
that is
part of the NLMops course
I just taught it here
by the way
MLflow is not the only option
you can use many more kinds of
software for experiment tracking
even the deep eval
company software
AI
weights and biases
software
there are many players in this
so the main idea is
don't catch the tool, catch the concept
so that if you understand the concept
then you will learn it in a week
because it is not necessary
that we teach you MLflow here
and send it to the company where you
get a job MLflow is used there too
it is not necessary
no standard tool has been established
for MLLms
for machine learning yes
MLflow has become the de facto standard
here no standard has been established
so focus on the concept
is it clear
whatever we discussed till now
till regression testing
is the concept clear?
summary is
after making the evaluation suite
we will also do regression testing
that will be
part of our evaluation strategy
regression testing
not experiment tracking
not CI
ok
now let's talk about the last step
once
now you have done
your regression testing
and you realized
that the readings of the new version of the software
its metrics
are better than the baseline
so what will you do now?
now you will deploy
that software
right, deployment will be done
but after deployment
the evaluation does not stop
I had taught you this
and we are going to do the same thing here
once the software is deployed
even after that
we will keep evaluating it
and this evaluation is called
online evaluation
now what all things you will do here
I will tell you quickly
here you measure 3-4 things
once the software is online
you measure 3-4 things
first you
capture some things
like
every time when a student
comes to our chatbot and asks doubts
then to answer his question
what is the latency
how much is the cost
did he give thumbs up
or thumbs down
you capture all these signals
quickly write to me in the chat
to do this whole thing
which software can we use
give me one software name
which we can use, I have shown you in the past
which software can we use for this work
to collect these signals
Lansmith
Langgraph
Langsmith is one option
we also have Lansfuse
in fact
Confident AI also works
we call it tracing
or observability
in the world of LLMs
so basically what we will do
we will add some
tracking code in our code
and by adding that tracking code
we will capture all the interactions
on our software when it is live
all the interactions related data
we will capture
latency, cost, tokens, thumbs up
thumbs down, all these things we will capture
and all that we will see
in one place in a dashboard
which is Lansmith's dashboard
apart from this
we will also compute some other values
these are captured values
whatever is coming, we are storing it as it is coming
but we will also capture some things
like when our software
is deployed
online
how is its faithfulness
or how is its answer relevance
or how is its correctness
the things we tested offline
the same things
we test online
so this is also our work
after that we
check drift
drift basically means
that over time our software
performance is not getting bad
I had told this in a lecture
that we have
a last 24 hours graph
in that we are tracking some metric
for example faithfulness
so suddenly in the last 8 hours
the curve of faithfulness is going down
so this is a kind of
drift which we are detecting
and with that we do alerting
and after alerting we improve it
so you have to do this whole thing
once the software
is deployed
after that we will do this
and lastly there will be
a self improving loop
which basically means
that sometime there will be a chat
with a student
where our software will misbehave
our application will misbehave
so we will pick up
those specific instances
and make our offline
eval part
our offline data set part
so that our offline data set
our golden data sets
get more enriched
so that when we make a new version in future
and when we evaluate it offline
then it
can be evaluated better
so that is why there is a loop
here
so this is how
the entire
evaluation strategy will be carried out
this is what I have thought for you
that we will make a rag application
and we will make it at this level
the whole page that you can see on the screen
we will test it
according to this
so my
plan of action is
that in the next class
I will
teach you
the complete component
level evaluation
which basically means that in the next class
I will make you a retriever
and then teach you to test the retriever
then I will make a generator
and then I will teach you to test the generator
and in the same process
you will do deep eval
for the first time
after that in the next session
we will build a rag pipeline
and we will
run this rag
triad
three metrics
after that
third session
or maybe it can be a little early
I don't really know because
I don't know how it will turn out in the future
we will run the entire evaluation
at the application level
and fourth, the final session
we will cover regression testing
and online eval
we will cover this
so basically in the next four sessions
the whole framework that we have made
of testing a rag application
we will practically
carry out
this is our road map
of the four sessions
I am not starting today because
this whole thing is
around two hours
and I want to do this in two hours in one stretch
I don't want to make you read
one hour today and then one hour on Saturday
the flow breaks down
so I have kept today's class specifically
to have this entire discussion
by the way I think
on the basis of today's session
you can kind of
tackle this question
don't you think?
do you think
if someone asks you this question now
how do you evaluate
your rag chatbot
will you be able to answer this question?
think about it, it's very simple
what you have to say is
first I will build an evaluation suite
that person will ask
what is an evaluation suite
you will say that I will test
my application at three levels
I will test it on the
component level where I
will test the retriever and generator
tell me the name of the metrics
then I will test it at the pipeline level
tell me rag triad
then I will test it at the application level
correctness, completeness
then I will test the safety and operation metrics
and once this whole thing is done
I will use all of these
and do regression testing
regression testing can also have three levels
basic, experiment tracking
CICD
I will operate at one level
according to my company
and once the regression testing is done
and I get a new baseline
I will deploy it
and even after deploying I will not stop
I will run online evaluations
what will you run online?
and I will make the mistakes there
and make my offline eval part
trust me on this
when you answer this
in the interview
then the other person will properly understand
because there is nothing
other than this rag evaluation
this is the answer to this question
what many people do
I have taken the interviews myself
so I can tell you when I ask the candidates
when I ask many people how to evaluate
the rag chatbot
a lot of people don't know this answer
because they have never read the evaluations
the people who have read the evaluations
the majority of the people answer this
that we will check the recall
we will check the precision
we will check the answer relevance
they take the name of 3-4 metrics
and they think that is the answer
but trust me there is a framework
when you will answer it
like a framework
then the other person will give you respect
that yes boss he knows
he has done it
so when you will practically do this
in the next 4 sessions
then it will be ingrained in your mind
and that is the idea
that in the next 4 sessions I have to create a resource
so that when anyone
wants to understand rag evaluation
then he will understand by seeing these 4 lectures
that is the whole idea
so yeah
we are ending this lecture on a promise
that the next 4 lectures
will be very interesting
so that is all for today
small session
let me know what are your thoughts
you will answer this question guys
this one, I think you will answer it now
I actually started speaking
so I didn't pay attention
do you feel you can answer better
than your competition
you are in a better place to answer this question
ok
so we will see this practically
there can be some plus or minus
which I have planned
because I have not done it practically
so there will be some improvisations
but largely
the framework we have discussed
we will stick to this
and you will see a better version of this
in the Himanchu course
so you are getting this treatment from both sides
and once we cover this
then we will move to the eval of agents
which is a little more difficult
and a little more tricky
but again it will be fun
so if you have any questions
you can ask
today's session is short
so if you have any questions
or doubts
then you can go
before that
an important thing
we have shared the last month's feedback form with you
give us feedback
if you have any complaints then write it
I have promised you
that your feedback is very important
we have made many changes in your last feedback
you must have seen it
so if you have any questions
then write it
we have made many changes in your last feedback
you must have seen it
so going forward
whatever is in our control we will definitely do
so please use your
feedback power
if you feel that you need any improvement
or any suggestion
then send it to us without hesitation
we will try our best
we talk about how to improve this
so trust me we need your feedback
it's kind of
it gives us direction
so
Harry
it's the same
4 more sessions will be
on the rag eval
and I think 4 more sessions will be
on the agent eval
so take 8 more sessions
please take one certification
session
what is
a certification?
can you share resource and books
if someone wants to deep down more
Ravi I will be very honest
this is a very new topic
and at this point
if there are books
then there is no standard set
that this book is very good for this topic
so
there is a good chance that what we are teaching you
is the most in depth
because we are actually taking a lot of time
so if I get some good resource
then I will definitely share
but I don't have
a single book in my mind
I have seen multiple books on this topic
but when I saw the books
I was not convinced that I should
recommend it
so at this point I cannot recommend
for someone who is acting as
a BA for AI agents
what is BA?
is BA
business analyst?
even if you are a
business analyst
this is
a good amount of depth
for you
for that matter
for any professional
this is a very good
level of depth
if you achieve this
you are able to make eval systems
it's more than enough
honestly
yeah Amir I have seen
I will unmute you in a while
I will take the chat questions
I am getting a lot of praise for the notes
we have actually
Himanshu and Sufal are working on this
they are building
some new system
this is the output
once the system becomes stable
we are testing it
we will start making it for everyone
we have available transcripts
we will make it for everyone
you will have to be patient
azure AWS certifications
or parul
this is our goal
teach you these conceptual things
like LLM Ops, LLME evals
system design
after teaching all this
we will work tool based
we will teach things around this
Sir, I think
the interviewer
in the book reading session
he doesn't seem interactive
Krishna I said the same thing
those who are coming from the industry
don't expect
from them
that they will teach like a teacher
because that person has worked in the industry
he doesn't have that much experience in teaching
so extract as much as you can
from that
we are there to teach
even if it seems boring
extract his experience
that would be my suggestion
I am saying again and again
if someone is coming from the industry
you will expect
from them
it is not possible
because that is not his main job
so extract his experience
that is important
we are there to teach
we will teach
please suggest which certificate
would help me stand out
Sneha I always keep one stand
I honestly feel
certifications don't
help you much
unless it is a very new certification
and it is getting very popular
I don't know if there is a new certification
of Claude
not many people will have it
but over time it will also saturate
so certificates
I personally don't find them very useful
especially if there is a cost attached
I would recommend not to do any kind
of certifications
but again
a new certification is coming from
an established company
in which not many people have enrolled
that could be a good certification
so Claude I think could be a good certification
right now in the AI age
because Claude is a leading provider
so that would be one option
Shagul business analyst
if you are a business analyst
then this level of depth
is a good amount of depth
if you do this I don't think there will be
more expectations from someone
plus when you learn this
then you will be able to understand
more than this
it is like you have a torch in your hand
and you have to go ahead in the jungle
and the light of the torch is 10 meters
so it does not mean that you are restricted
to 10 meters
if you go ahead 10 meters
then you go ahead 10 meters
which basically means that if you are able to
handle this level of depth
then automatically your appetite to
handle more depth increases
so that will start happening automatically
so don't think about what level you have to learn
now what we are bringing for you
understand that
upgrade yourself automatically
your horizon will expand
you will be able to understand more
see more, decode more
where to find the feedback
feedback, survey
the first session
in the whatsapp group
whatsapp group is there so far I guess
for deployment
can there be any specific sessions
we will do it in LLM ops
it is not part of this course
we will teach you deployment in LLM ops
so the old videos
we can generate transcripts
with the help of AI tool
actually we are doing it but it is a slow process
so we are not promising it
because if we promise it then you will be surprised
that where are the notes
so rather than surprise it is a better strategy
that here it is done
rather than promising upfront
and then failing
any other question guys
I guess I have answered all the questions
I was talking about unmuting someone
prioritizing the system design course
would be very helpful
so I will tell you upfront
what is my plan
this course will be over
after this we will do one more course
which will be
AI security and governance course
which is now getting popular in the market
it will be a shorter course
it won't be that big
once it happens
I have completed a stretch
of the whole thing
right from the line chain to this point
then I will teach you AI system design
so there is a good chance
that mid of October
or maybe
last of October
we will start system design
and complete it in November-December
with system design
our entire AI engineering track
will be completed
because context engineering
we are going to provide
LLM Ops, LLM evals
we have taught agents in Langraph
we will teach you how to make
multi agent systems
so we can conduct some workshop
so basically we will cover this entire site
and then from New Year
our plan is to move to builder side
so right from where we have left
on the transformer
we will start from there
and then we will do LLM Ops
builder side
so that is our goal
so you might feel a little frustrating
that in what order we are covering
how slowly we are doing
but I have always had two goals
first is that
the upper level plan
which I had made a roadmap
at the beginning of this year
I have to complete it
I am completing it bit by bit
me along with my colleagues
we should not be slow
even if we are slow
these are the two philosophies we are following
and I can totally understand
if you are relying on our courses
or playlists
then you might feel the speed is frustrating
but I will be honest
sometimes I literally
intentionally slow it down
because I feel that I am not getting complete control
on this topic
I mean I can deliver it
on 70% but I stall it
or I don't take today's class
because I need more time
I need more clarity
that is why it slows down a little bit
but the goal is always that
if something comes from our side
then it should fit in your mind
so sorry if we disappoint you
but
our intention is very pure
I can tell you that
yeah yeah I know
all the interviews are focusing on that
project will be very helpful
yeah project is also
in the pipeline
we will make a complete course
which will have 4-5 projects on gen.ai systems
so we have to do that
I will not take that
Ajay will do that but yeah
sir I am a web developer
so can I directly start
landchain for AI engineering role or MLDL
no you can start directly
no need for MLDL
you can see my playlist
it will come in the next class
can we have a deep dive on deep agent in between
I mean I can try
but I am not completely
convinced about deep
agents right now
that is why I am giving it some time
so once that window gets completed
in my mind then I will take that topic
it happens a little
that it crosses a threshold
that topic that yes universally
it has been accepted that now everyone is
following the concept
so then it is useful to teach it otherwise
then it becomes a waste of effort
someone
was talking about unmuting
who asked to unmute
I forgot the name
Amar is it Amar
Amar jeet
what is happening here
raise your hand again
Amar
then I
yeah
speak
you can speak
I have two questions
first
let's say if we are experimenting
we have to start again
sorry I couldn't hear the question from the beginning
I have two questions
first question is
how do we generate embedding
for a particular document
let's say the chunk size overlapping
can we version that
let's say if I am experimenting
I can change my embedding two or three times
but in ten experiments
I want to use the setting
of two or three embedding
so rather than
burn my costing on embedding
or if I want to
do caching
embedding
let's say
the chunk size of 1000
overlap of 50
one setting is my embedding
and I am using a model of Olamas
so I am using it for embedding
so you want to save your embedding cost
yes sir
I understood your point
let me tell you the answer
in the next class
by finding the exact solution
and the second question
yes tell
answer second
there was a second request sir
if you can teach this course
like py test
and asynchronous programming
so that will be
helpful in the
product
we have already studied py test
if you go to python course
you have 40 courses
and one of them is python
in advanced python
section
we have studied py test
Hemanshu have you studied py test
yes
we have studied async await
but
I can tell you the upfront of async await
how is async await
that it should be a proper course
otherwise it can't be understood
by watching one video or two videos
that is the topic
I thought of making a course in between
but it is like hardcore software
engineering topic
so there
I couldn't make it because I didn't have time
but there are a lot of things to cover
so we will cover it
it might take 8 to 10 hours
so we have
some videos and some online
from good youtube channels
we have explained async await in python
understand the basic concept
don't try to understand it at the code level
unless you are a software developer
and you want to go for interviews
the code will be generated
you should know the concept
when you need async
that is the main thing
so it will take a lot of time and effort
it is a difficult topic
in software programming
unless you are directly required
that will be my suggestion for now
rest of the things
you will get access
we have it in our course
we have it in online youtube
chat gpt cloud
yes
kori shafur
has a good video
but I saw it a couple of times
I couldn't control it
any other question?
neo4j semantic layer is also
hyping in the industry
yes, it is the same
look at tools
any provider
is on the rise
and if it is operating in an adjacent domain
it will definitely
bring its own solution in the market
and this is happening
every leading player
in the MLDL domain
or in the software
it is bringing something of its own
tooling
now it is difficult to do everything
because mostly the concept is same
you
evaluation, tracing, observability
monitoring, alerting
these are the domains
so we want you
to understand things in a conceptual level
so that tomorrow
if you read some documentation
or watch a video
you will understand
that is the main idea
to prepare you conceptually
fundamentally
because today is there, tomorrow will not be there
nobody knows
people are mostly using async functions
yeah, obviously it is true
this is what you have to do
I will give you a simple example
you are running an evaluation on your software
let's say you have deployed
and you have to do
online evaluations
so you will have to run
online evaluations in asynchronous
if you run it in synchronous
then the latency of your app will increase
because now you have to give a chat response
but if you have done it in synchronous
then you have to evaluate it
you have to log it somewhere
so that's why evaluations
tracing, all that is asynchronous
so asynchronous is a very important
aspect of programming
so you have to learn
it is a good thing but it is a difficult concept
it takes time to understand and teach
that is why I said that understand basic level
syntax and understand where
the usage is
the rest of the code is generated
nobody is writing from today
so there should be some building
if understanding is there
that is good enough
will we have some classes on multi-agent
architectures
yes, we are planning to conduct one workshop
kind of setup
by the way, we are conducting a workshop this month
you might have seen the schedule
we are conducting a workshop on
building voice AI agents
so we have thought
that we can pick a topic like this
and teach you
we are conducting a workshop on voice AI agents
next month we can conduct a workshop
on multi-agent architecture
that is also a bit out of date
we will teach you that too
I have not worked on
graph databases
or knowledge bases
till now, I am very interested
in learning about
the applications
that are available
so I am going to
teach you the
basic code of
the application
that is the basic code
I am very interested
but unfortunately
I have not been able to do work on it
so I will ask
Himanshu and Ajay
if they have worked on a graph database
or knowledge database
they will be able to guide you
Himanshu is saying
that graph rag
was covered in advance rag
so from there you can get some idea
most likely you will be building graph rag
I guess
but yes, it is a very interesting thing
there are many applications
that
can be represented in the form of
graph even in gen AI
ok then guys
I guess that's it for
today, in the next class
we will start rag evaluation
this is the common
we will start from exactly
the same, the whole side is
on the transformer
so we will start from exactly the same
decoder only, encoder only, encoder decoder only
we will discuss the whole era
and after that we will
start your
tokenization, data curation
pre-training, fine
tuning, alignment, that will be the whole track
so we will do that next year
we will cover
the two years
that you have with us
most likely
are we covering clip
we will cover clip too but once
my plan is
to cover LLMs then
we will go to LMMs
large multimodal models
so
we will not cover multimodal in the beginning
we will do the textual one only
one iteration will happen
then we will do multimodal
sir if possible
can we have a session on async
await that will give us confidence in using it in life
ok I will try
but I will be very honest
in two hours you will not be able to learn it properly
it will need more
because you will have to come
from a very long time, multitasking, multiprocessing
all those concepts will have to be picked
from there it will have to be built
I had made a curriculum
about 6 months ago
for async await
and in that I had
created a very good progression
from where to start
what to read, on the first principle basis
but then that course
could not manifest
so what I can do is
maybe I can arrange a session
I myself
want to teach
but again on the same priority basis
we are operating
ok
any other question
with the
storytelling
you have to learn
like data storytelling
or what
data storytelling
yeah
for that you will have to come up with a project
yeah that is correct
data storytelling
as you go to the business side
there is a lot of demand for data storytelling
I can totally understand
many of my friends also tell me
that when they
better present
the narrative
of what is going on in data
then people get impressed
and then they take a different trajectory
of their career
so yeah that is true
I don't know maybe
we can have one session around that
but that is it, out of all these topics
priority is coming down
because most of the people
they are like a younger
population
1-3-5 years of experience level
but yeah as you go
to the business side
data storytelling becomes huge
we will try
ok guys
so we will close the session
and see you on saturday
first rag eval lecture
ok
so yeah good night
let's meet on saturday
bye